que ce soit une scène de crime des
animaux ou encore une sarbacane géante
voilà des situations et des loisirs
difficile à imaginer entre collègues
et pourtant c'est bien l'objectif de ce
premier salon du tourisme d'affaires
proposer aux entreprises des solutions
innovantes lorsqu'elles cherchent à
renforcer la cohésion de leur équipe
on est vraiment sur un objectif de
travailler ensemble de la cohésion
fédérer les équipes on est vraiment sur
cette thématique aulas a travaillé
ensemble dans un but commun que ce soit
sortir d'une pièce en 90 minutes ou
alors résoudre l'énigme le meurtre qui a
été commis on essaye de trouver des
idées un petit peu plus sympathique un
simple dîner autour d'un événement
particulier
donc d'où l'idée de d'animations
particulières
voilà les scènes de crime là derrière je
pense que ça peut être très sympa près
d'une cinquantaine de prestataires
étaient présents à la ferme du manet
pour répondre à une demande en pleine
croissance le tourisme d'affaires c'est
un marché de plus de 4 milliards d'euros
en ile de france avec ses seize mille
société et ses nombreuses installations
sportives et culturelles l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines souhaite
profiter de cette dynamique en parlant
en échangeant sur différentes sur
différents rendez vous on s'est rendu
compte que d'une part il y avait une
véritable offre que les partenaires ne
se connaissaient pas forcément donc
c'était bien de les réunir et ensuite
que les entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines était sans doute demandeuses
d'événements mais qu'elle n'en avait pas
connaissance et le marché semble promis
à un bel avenir pour les entreprises
spécialisées du territoire la ryder cup
en 2018 est très certainement les jeux
olympiques en 2024 seront à coup sûr des
porteurs d'affaires à leur mesure